Maybe I'll make a fuss like before, or worse, I'll get attacked. Well
then, it's my turn for the first time in a while.
This is the secret treasure of Ashira Bopal Bunny. Mr. Sangaku, please
don't use the tag.
Oh,
Metamorphose, I'm
surprised. If this is the case, I'll be suspicious.  It's
crazy that I can enter the town without being able to do anything.I should have been
playing Shangri-La Frontier, the catchphrase of which is to open the world of Shinge, which Japan is proud of, and enjoy the world.Sanra-san, I'm a
girl who is a beast personified.  And
Sarah: Well, I'm
playing a slow-paced career game,
but it's really tiring, so I'll believe it again if I stay there.In my
current state, 45 minutes is the limit.I
see, if you invade the town, you have to use the shadows to unlock it.  I don't think you
should, but Elle, you
seem to be deadly. You're really famous.
[Music]
Bhopal Rabbit
Ah.